so on saturday chris evans accidentally
leaked his own news look at the smile on
her face smelling her face
i love captain america yeah first and
foremost um did you see the picture
uh no i did it so it was a screen
recording
let me see that tweet kevin uh evan uh
chris evans publicist after
logging in twitter let me see that yeah
[Applause]
he also had this photo on his uh photo
roll
yeah and this is what people are also
making fun of him it was like a phone
a really dark photo of his dick and then
a meme that somebody made
of him saying guard that [ __ ] that's
awkward there's a couple things first of
all
everybody
[Laughter]
everybody listen erase the dick pics on
your phone bruh
that's hilarious
how i mean let me see that one
that's actually hilarious how i mean has
somebody not put a meme
of the shield over the tip of his dick
yet i mean somebody
had to have right what was the exact
picture
so uh he did a post on instagram where
on his story he put a he did a screen
recording
from his phone of a video of him and a
friend playing the heads up game
that like ellen guessing game and when
the video stops it goes back to your
camera roll and you get to see like the
little blocks of your photos
the last thing that was posted yeah
within that timeline and one of the
photos was the guard that [ __ ]
but it was yeah another one is just a
picture of his dick oh that's a bummer
but here's the thing everyone who saw it
loves his dick
he's been getting good reviews is it is
that the size dick have you seen it i
haven't seen it
you have the picture chin it they got
deleted they got deleted i'm sure his
team's just pulling
and a lot of people if you hadn't
pulling it
dick pick out that people loved would
you pull it down
if you had an act i mean it's already
out there so for him
he's like all right so now if you're
already chris evans
you're already a huge movie star you
already have that body and
now you have a good dick like i'm
leaving it out there
i'm leaving it my publicist might be
like take that down i'm like
what is the negative to having a good
dick pic out there
it was this one right which one that
this one
it's so hard to tell so that's the i
think that that's the tip
don't play coi it's at the top or the
bottom
i did see the picture and it was i
thought it was like huge it's just
embarrassing
it's like thick too thick and big do you
think he i'm just saying
his mouth is watering
right now is that a i'm telling you and
then i'm definitely naming my dick
after one of the avengers like how is he
not
naming his dick captain america don't
bring it out
you know that poor guy i mean i would
obviously uh blurt out
sure okay that's a shitty deal what else
you got cat
how about when i get off stage with the
lap factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what just run a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler we got a [ __ ]
together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son